thank you for that another party
happening in Henderson tonight fans
gathering at Water Street Plaza to cheer
the team onto Victory and that's where
we find eight news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough with more
what a way to start the week as the
Vegas golden knights are now NHL
champions and fans arriving as early as
11 A.M to watch the big game on the big
screen here on Water Street
it was a packed lawn on Water Street
Plaza in Henderson as hundreds gathered
to watch the Vegas golden knights beat
out the Florida Panthers in what was
their final game to Victory winning the
Stanley Cup
here's what some hockey fans had to say
it's absolutely amazing I've been a
golden ice match since day one I just
it's not second any I can't believe it
it was finally our time it's my one year
anniversary in Las Vegas and I just
truly feel that this was meant to happen
go nice go this is our Dream this is a
dream um I follow so many
uh games and finally the cup is ours
because I've been a sports fan since I
was like five years old and this is huge
this is I love this I almost cried right
over there I got on my knees I bowed
down to the cup I love this and with
this big win come celebration on the
Strip just like for the Las Vegas Aces
who took home the 2022 WNBA title dates
and times for The Night Celebration
parade will soon be announced reporting
here in Henderson Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now